part three is really the the weird part
okay that's the part which stops
everyone but enough people got stopped
by parts one and two then i figure i
might as well just go back over those as
well okay so
if you've got the paper there or at
least what you did you're working here's
where you start you get given the
standard equations of motion for your
projectile motion
and what you've got to prove is the
equation of path okay so do you remember
how to do this even if you don't
remember anything about projectile
motion you have a look at what this is
this is an equation between y and x so
what you've got to do is eliminate your
parameter t okay
and the way you're going to do it is you
want to you want a y equals equation
okay so the stuff from here is going to
go into here and not the other way
around okay
so being that i want to eliminate my
parameter okay i'm going to make the
parameter the subject of this first
equation so if i take the x equation
what's t going to be equal to from that
equation
dx
yeah good
okay so
now that we have established that all
you do is sub this call that one into
this and it'll fall out okay but because
it's all in like you the result is given
all of the marks are in the process you
go through to get there okay so let's go
ahead and do it
when i sub in my x on v cos theta i'm
going to have one of them up the front
here
squared right there's my t squared and
i'm gonna have the other one here
okay now again because it's uh it's a
show it's a prove it's a it's a
demonstrate kind of question okay you
can't go ahead and skip steps right so
you can't go from here
um to one plus tan squared theta even
though it's true okay we've got to make
the identities clear so let's go ahead
and do that you're going to have your
minus
put the geometry there x squared i put
these out separately just so i can make
it more obvious and this is your sec
squared theta right
okay you've got it you've got to have
that step okay because that's where you
get this identity from
then here
these cancel that's okay and your sine
theta and cos theta that's all right
there's no other there's no intermediate
step between sine theta and cos theta
and tan okay so you're going to have
your x tan theta there and that part's
done which is nice okay
i'll stick that out the front because
it's in the front in what they want us
to produce
and i want to start to rearrange this
business because i want to get it
towards that where h is what is it it's
like
uh two v squared or no hollow b square b
squared on 2g right yeah sorry that's
right
okay so if i want to get towards that i
want to have that nice and clear out the
front and i have to have it upside down
it's just slightly awkward but it'll be
useful later okay so what am i going to
have i've got my
minus
g on 2v squared
uh
x squared and now i can turn that into
my one plus transport okay
okay i think that's that's basically
enough i mean you can see here
where this is going to go and they've
provided that value of h2 okay so i
think it's enough to
then give the provider
what would i do i threw an extra
hold on what did i move did i forget to
add that is that what i forgot yeah yeah
that's right that's better
okay
that's it that's long age
okay now
um you may ask the question why they
bother proving uh asking us to prove
this given result of two other given
results when it's like you know are they
just trying to pad out the number of
marks
and the answer is no they're trying to
give you a clue for questions two and
three okay now the equation of path is
useful to us right
because it reframes a question which is
about different kinds of velocities into
just a cartesian sort of problem okay so
in other words it's a quadratic and we
know heaps about quadratics okay
but the interesting thing about this
kind of quadratic is it's two quadratics
same time can you see it
it's a quadratic in x that's the obvious
one because you've got your you know um
one solution here another solution there
depending on where you fight from right
but you can see it's also a quadratic in
if i stick y here
you've got your tan squared and your tan
theta there that's why like why do they
bother why not just leave it as sec
squared that's fine isn't it well it's
to try and make it more obvious that
it's a quadratic and tan theta okay
which becomes crucially important in
parts two and three
i'm also part two all right so there you
go there's part one there's your
equation apart let's keep moving through